[Music]
bernie is with us bernie is in
massachusetts hi bernie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
well two years ago we had a
paid off house and about four thousand
dollars in the bank
and no no debt
and then our house burned
down
yeah it was a total loss wow um how
traumatic yeah
oh yeah we even lost our pets we didn't
even know shoes like it was it was good
it was bad
a couple days before christmas you know
standing there in 17 degree weather wow
but
anyhow we were
well insured
and we have since rebuilt
um
and you know i'm i'm a cheapskate so
when we were going through this process
i was extremely
deliberate and frugal
bought some of my light fixtures at
architectural supply uh
salvage places whatever so anyhow we
came out
pretty good we now again have a paid for
house
but i now have
about a hundred thousand dollars extra
because i bought used furniture i didn't
run out to the furniture store and
replace everything i own with brand new
stuff
so
i would like to know the best way to use
that money
wow we didn't have any retirement
accounts beforehand
just before thousand dollars right how
old are you guys
my husband is 69 and i'm 62 this month
okay
sounds like you need it as a nest egg
doesn't it
yeah
the outside of the house is still not
finished i mean like the ground we've
still got like a dirt path to the front
door and we haven't paved the driveway
he locks right now we're very low
no i don't know if i should hang on to
the money or you need to you need to set
a budget to finish the house
can you finish
the outdoors work can you finish the
house for under a hundred thousand
i'm sure okay oh sure finish the house
finish the house and invest what's left
okay what like a mutual fund yep your
house is not finished though
so you don't have a hundred thousand
dollars left
because you don't have a driveway
you have a dirt path to the front yard
you're not a hillbilly you need a dadgum
sidewalk out there
well yeah i think we could finish that
up for probably about twenty thousand
okay then you got eighty thousand
dollars
is that is the house actually finished
then
yes we're living in it no i'm when you
put twenty thousand dollars in the
driveway on the sidewalk are you
done oh yeah okay what is your it would
you have income from any other sources
uh my husband collects 1600 a month in
social security
i have not filed yet for social security
even though i'm 62 this month i'm
exploring i don't know if i should file
yet or not
and one of the things we did when we
rebuilt
was i looked at the garage and the size
of the garage and thought boy that's a
lot of space above that garage so we put
in an in-law apartment when we built and
i have a son
who's renting from us
so we're getting an extra 600 a month
from the
in-law apartment okay
it sounds like you need to invest the 80
000 and create some extra income for you
all to live on
yeah in in good mutual funds and sit
down with a smart vester pro click smart
buster pro at ramsey solutions select
one in your area and sit down with them
but don't do that and have a dirt path
to your front door
finish the house
and because you're gonna be living there
a long time
and that dirt path is gonna be
a reminder of the trauma
that the the the fire was
and the fire a fire trauma losing
everything pets and everything in the
house fire is that's a it's in one of
the it's on that list of one of the 10
things that can put you in the hospital
from stress
yeah that's very emotional and uh bernie
like dave's saying the point of the baby
steps is not to be miserable and so i
don't want you guys to sacrifice a level
where you have a dirt path going up to
your house and you have you know college
dorm room furniture because you're
sacrificing i want you guys to enjoy the
things that you have and you can do that
without going crazy i mean it sounds
like you're very frugal already but i
don't want you to go nuts on this stuff
so do what you need to do to get the
house in order to where you enjoy living
in it and you can get to the front door
and then invest the rest like dave's
talking about so that you guys can
retire with dignity
now now keep in mind if you make ten
thousand dollars on eighty thousand
that's eight thousand dollars a year
okay so we're only talking about a few
hundred dollars a month we're adding to
your budget it's not a ton but it'll
help some just like the mother-in-law
apartments helping some with the sun
with the kid reading it and all that and
so you just keep taking those little
steps but you're going to make these you
do not have a big monthly income
with all these things added together you
still don't have a big monthly income
and so you're gonna have your your
social security check's gonna start
pretty quick because you're gonna need
to add that to this pile
to be able to uh live on what you guys
are actually making
unless there's income coming from
somewhere that you did not outline for
some reason here yeah or that we didn't
understand do you have a rule of thumb
for when to take out that social
security depending on your situation
well in her case it sounds like she's
got to take it out because she's i think
they're starving it's necessary um but
um
you know if you don't need it the longer
you wait the bigger the check is
but um you know me i you know i'd get it
as soon as i could get it because i want
to get all i can get out of the
government before i die fort runs out
which sounds like it might happen yeah
you just never know